Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
I was, the past two days, working.
Yes, although it says rest day or until the next heist, I'm still working.
There's no stopping with the work.
Oh my god, there's so much behind the scenes stuff to do.
Oh yeah, because I'm the boss now, I can talk about this stuff without having to worry about like, can I talk about this?
I'm the boss!
I say I can talk about this!
So like, one of the things that I was very stressed out about, by the way...
Oh my god, opening a store and running a store.
Running a store is so hard.
Oh my gosh.
Because there's a lot of things that can happen.
Because we're all starting out, my team is just starting out.
I'm just starting out running a John-ass store.
Like, you know, the best I have done was Etsy and Artist Alley.
So like, you said rest day!
Well, I didn't say who's gonna be resting.
What?
I'm not lying that you're the one that's resting, not me!
The thing about being a streamer is that technically there's no actual rest days when you're a streamer.
Because you're always working.
Like, you give yourself the rest day because your whole job is to stream and to like keep up your platform, your social platform and all that fucking shit.
If I was... that's why I'm playing Supermarket Simulator so I can be like, I can be a real person.
You know.
It's not like I'm working at a supermarket where I just... where I just check in, do my hours and then check out and not have to worry about the supermarket anymore.
Instead, as a streamer, we always have to worry about everything.
Stream ends!
You think we stop working?
Well, like for some people, maybe.
But for me, I'm still working.
Because I have to like, make sure that I, you know, make sure that I still have an income coming in.
Yeah, I might make rest day for Amber.
You don't know that.
Anyway.
Um.
Thank you, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Okay, anyway.
Where was I?
Okay, yes.
Anyway.
Running a store is incredibly difficult.
It is such a huge learning process.
Especially opening up the store to more and more, uh, to more and more like people from different countries.
So, one of the biggest issue, like mistake I found out yesterday.
Um, I was like looking through like, uh, cause like finally I had time to look through like the orders and the, um, the payments and stuff like that.
And the analytics.
So, I was looking at the store analytics yesterday.
And then I noticed.
I was like, this only applied to the Lunar New Year merch, by the way.
So, like do not worry about like, oh my gosh, Tokyo, what about your other merch?
Are you okay with the other merch?
So, this only applied to the Lunar...
Yeah, this is the pain of being self-employed.
The Lunar New Year merch.
So, I was looking.
And I was like, oh, okay.
Someone ordered the Lunar New Year Recall X stand.
So, then I was like, alright.
Okay.
And then I looked at it.
And I realized, wait a minute.
Why is the stand $3 shipping?
I was like, that's for stickers.
And then I was like, oh, okay.
I realized almost everybody that ordered individual Lunar New Year stands were paying $3 for shipping.
So, I was like freaking out.
Because I was like, okay.
Shipping is not $3.
I might be trying to make shipping cheaper.
But it's definitely not $3.
So, then I was like, oh my gosh.
What the fuck happened?
So, there was like a mistake.
And somehow only the Lunar New Year acrylic stand was there.
And the stand got affected by this.
Thankfully, it's changed now.
It's changed.
It was changed yesterday night when we caught it.
But like, I'm taking the loss because obviously like we're all still starting out.
And everything.
And so, like I don't want to refund that.
Because it was like, the mistake was on our side.
And not on the customer's side.
So, like I was like, okay.
It wasn't that bad.
It was only like 50 people bought the stand.
So, I was like, I can tank 50 people.
Like, I can't even.
I was just like, it wasn't really a loss.
Like, there's still profits going on.
It's just people who individually ordered the stand.
Like, it's just that.
And I was like, it's alright.
It's like, it's just, it's fine.
Like, there's still a profit for it.
It's just...
Um...
You know, regarding that.
It's just like, they're still paying for that.
So, I was like, it's fine.
It's fine.
I'll just...
I can tank the cost for them.
Okay.
It's just the longer I do this, the more experience we're gonna get.
So, it's okay.
I'm happy to take the mistakes now.
Then later on.
Because I'll be like, okay.
If it was like...
Oh my god.
I'm so thankful for the 50 gift ships.
Thank you.
Masters, thank you for the 50 gift ships.
I really appreciate it.
But I was like, I'd rather we make these mistakes now than later down on the line when it will be a...
Like, if it was a thousand people, then we would have an issue.
But like, no.
Like, I'd rather just take it now than later on down the line.
So, we've learned.
Our team has learned.
We've learned as we go along.
Building more and more experience points.
So, yeah.
So, I was going through that.
But it's okay.
Like, we're not losing money.
In the end, even though that happened, we're not losing money.
So...
It's just that, like, regarding that, it's just not like as much profit versus the other...
If this shipping was like the right cost.
Like...
Like, it's just a couple of dollars.
Like, the shipping.
Because like, normally, the shipping would be like seven to eight dollars instead of three.
So, like, I was like, okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Like, I'm willing to take that.
And it wasn't that big of an amount.
So...
Um...
Robin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I was like, it wasn't a thousand.
I'm okay.
It didn't even hit a hundred.
It only...
It was two digits.
It's fine.
So, I was doing...
I was handling...
Because I was like thinking, this is a learning experience for the team and I.
Handling a store is like one of the hardest.
I think like everything...
The store is definitely the hardest thing to deal...
To deal with.
Because like, obviously, there's like so many factors.
And then like also like the currency...
The...
Uh...
Currency...
Like converting and everything.
Um...
And it's just...
Oh, my God, it is...
It's a lot.
Yeah.
So, I hope that like...
I got...
I get...
Like my team and I get better and better as we go along.
Oh, my God.
And also like, I have a like...
I have a meeting with my accountant and then also like a meeting with my Canadian friends.
I'm a Canadian business lawyer for like regarding like drafting up contracts and stuff like we we are we're working on an NDA contract for like people we hire and everything.
And I was like, oh my god, I just I just want to stream funny games.
I just want to stream silly games like Supermarket Simulator.
Just want to be a funny anime girl.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
I was like, I need like my Mr. Matt and my mom was like, you need to have.
They're like, did you let this did you or any of the artists you hired in this side?
And he is I was like, No, I'm an indie like, no, Doki!
You need to have For your safety, we need to have these contracts ready.
I'm like, I'm trying guys.
I'm trying.
We need to protect yourselves.
I know.
I'm doing my best.
So yeah, anyway.
Anyway.
I was like dealing with a lot of the work stuff for that.
So, being my own boss is a lot.
It's definitely a lot of stuff going on.
There's been a lot of meetings I had to attend.
A lot of meetings I had to attend.
A lot of contracts I had to sign.
I was like, oh my god.
But I can also delegate my work too.
So I'm not doing everything myself.
I delegate it to other people.
So I'll be like, you do that.
And you do that.
So at best, I don't even have to attend that many meetings.
Because my team is like, my team attends a lot of my meetings too.
And then they just like, tell me what's going on.
And I'm like, that's great.
I'm just like, thank fucking god.
Thank god.
Oh yeah!
Another little bit of announcement.
I got invited to do a...
a...
I don't know when this is going to be.
It's not this week by the way.
But I got invited to do a JP Apex tournament.
I don't know when it...
I don't remember when it's going to be.
It's not this week.
That's not the special Apex stream by the way.
That's not the Apex special stream.
It's a different one.
So I'll be participating in a Japanese Apex tournament.
In the nearby future.
I don't remember what the date it is.
I should write stuff down.
I really should.
I should write stuff down more.
I'm going to be in the cloud with Amelie on Saturday.
I saw people were like, who is it going to be Doki?
Who are you going to play with?
The two other people.
I don't even know because we haven't asked anybody.
I was just like...
I put that down.
People think that I know.
It's like a surprise.
But like I put it down because we haven't asked who the two people are.
We haven't even asked people yet.
Because I was just like, I just want to put my schedule up.
I just want to put my schedule up.
So I was just like...
I was just like...
I just love how everyone was like, Oh my god, I wonder if it's these guys.
I was like, I don't know.
Me too.
I don't even know who they are going to be too.
Whoa!
It's a surprise for everyone.
Including me.
Alright, let's actually play Supermarket Simulator.
Let's go.
I was like reading the like what's upcoming.
And I love how cleaning is there.
And I was like, oh thank god I'm playing.
Thank god they haven't pushed out the cleaning update yet.
I really, really don't want to clean.
So I was like, oh thank god.
That's like one thing I'm glad it's not in there.
So, oh my god.
Shoplifters!
Security guards.
CCTV.
Oh my god.
This is going to be like too real.
Why work at your local supermarket?
Why you can play Supermarket Simulator?
You can play around.
Veggie and fruits.
Buying a house.
I don't need a house.
I can live in the supermarket.
The supermarket has everything I need.
Just like that MrBeast video.
Where like that couple lived in the supermarket for a fucking month or some shit.
Cas!
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Are you planning to create a code for Fortnite in the future?
My V-Bucks yearn to be spent.
Um, yes in the future.
There's like some stuff going on around that.
Because I'm trying to transfer.
Figure out a way to get my V-Bucks to be spent.
And I'm trying to transfer.
My skins to...
I'm just trying to figure out if there is any way.
To do that Because I spent around like almost 600 plus dollars on Fortnite skins.
Because I have a problem regarding Fortnite skins.
But.
I would say that whatever creative code you're using, it still works.
The money for that code still goes to me.
I'll just say that.
That's all I can say.
So until then, you can keep using whatever code you have.
I'm kidding.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Gotta get the Hey Peter skin.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So like that's all I can say about that.
The reason why we don't have a new code yet is because I'm trying to get my fucking Fortnite skins back.
So the moment I can get my skins back, there will be a new code.
Because I don't give a fuck about anything else on that account.
I just want my fort...
I need you guys to know, like when I did have a job that day... time.
I bought more Fortnite skins as retail therapy and I had a John Cena skin on there.
And I swear to God, I need those skins back!
I spent so much money...
I need all those skins...
I spent so much money.
I bought so many.
I bought a lot.
I have a John Cena skin on there now.
I have the... what was it?
The perfect cell skin because I thought I would be funny with the basketball.
I need them.
I need them back.
Mr. Man is working on it.
Mr. Man said it's possible to get my skins back.
That's all I want.
Last order.
Thank you for the 10.
Give this shit.
Thank you.
Oh no, chat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
John Cena skin is so OP.
Nobody can see you.
Let's play the actual supermarket.
Alright.
Welcome to the supermarket simulator.
You'll start with a small store and grow to an awesome supermarket.
I'm gonna be whole... what is it?
Whole Greens?
What is that super expensive like suburban mom supermarket?
I wanna be that.
I want...
Everything is like times three expensive.
Whole Foods!
I wanna be Whole Foods!
We're gonna be the better Whole Foods.
Start by purchasing goods to sell and place them onto shelves.
Don't forget to set prices to avoid a profit.
With profit to avoid bank... I can do that.
Oh my god.
That's... alright.
Let's turn now.
Let's do... oh, it's only hot.
Where's my...
This is my ultra ultra setting for this game.
Order using the computer.
Alright.
Okay.
Market.
We're gonna have cereal...
How much money do I have?
How much money?
Okay, we have $50.
Not a lot to start a supermarket.
Okay, we're not gonna have cereal.
Cereal is not... not a lot.
Not a lot of people that are awake in the...
No, actually!
We start with cereal.
Because the people who are awake this early... that need cereal.
Have money.
Actually, no.
They're students.
Never mind.
Fucking... No, moms!
Moms will buy!
Moms will need cereal for their children.
And we all know...
If the moms have kids...
Okay, usually...
Then they can afford good ass cereal.
Alright.
Okay, we're gonna have cereal.
Alright, and then... Everybody loves pasta.
Who doesn't love pasta?
Alright, cereal and pasta.
This is gonna be our store.
We're just... We're just gonna have cereal.
Cereal and pasta.
That's fine.
Moms need to cook too!
They need to cook!
Okay?
They need cereal and pasta.
Alright, how do I show?
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Here's my pasta.
There's my...
Is that cereal pasta?
There's my pasta.
And then...
Nexy, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you.
Can I get my... No!
Why?
Okay.
I'm not very good at this.
I'm not very good at shelving.
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm new here.
This is my store and I'm new here.
Nexy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, set the price.
Okay.
Market price is...
0.2 Okay, 2.
Wait, market price is 312?
Then it should be 4.
Right?
4...
No, no.
It should be 5 dollars.
5.99.
No.
Nothing... Nothing ever goes wrong with 5.99.
Okay, market price is...
That's some expensive cereal!
Is cereal that expensive?
I haven't had cereal in years, guys.
Ever since I stopped going to school.
Thank you for the...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I hope she made lots of spaghetti.
There's no way... There is no way cereal is that expensive now.
Is inflation fucked up that hard?
Are we...
Are we in the bad type of inflation now?
All inflation is bad, by the way.
Dude, what?
8.99 is like common?
For cereal?
Are you see...
Are you guys...
899?
Bro!
It doesn't even come with toys anymore!
They don't even come with toys!
Cereal is over 10 dollars!
We're at a live!
Bro!
You know what?
Maybe we should go to the supermarket.
Maybe capitalism is a bad idea.
Hello, sir.
Will you buy my 8.99 cereal?
Oh my god!
Pass is too expensive!
You bought the cereal!
Alright.
Giving zero dollars.
There's nothing to give.
How do I...
Approve...
Insufficient...
Oh, wait.
91.
You gave me 100 dollars for your fucking cereal?
Okay.
60...
70... 80...
91.
There we go.
I can't believe it.
This man gave 100 dollars.
Dude, what the do?
Okay.
I can't believe this is too expensive.
I can't believe it.
It says market price is 3 dollars.
Like 3.12...
This should have been fine.
Okay.
Boop.
Oh, credit card.
Oh, thank god.
8.99.
Yay!
How is the pass is too expensive?
I don't understand!
Okay.
Okay, fine.
I'll lower it.
I'm gonna lower it to 59 cents.
Alright?
There.
And this is the guy who thought the cereal was 100 bucks.
Many thank you for the server chat.
Thank you.
I don't understand!
How could it be that expensive?
I need money!
This is fucked up.
This is so fucked up.
Alright.
Customization.
Storage.
Wait, I want to rename my store.
I want me to rename it to Better Whole Foods.
I can't believe it.
Oh, I can have...
I can take a loan.
It is so too expensive!
Fine!
Five...
Okay.
Four...
dollars.
Is that fine?
Fine!
Four dollars.
No, that's way too cheap, man.
Four...
Food.
4.50.
Take it or leave it.
Oh, she took it!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
She did take it!
Nice!
Okay.
Thirty...
Six...
Uh...
Five... one...
Fifty... one...
Quick maths.
Ha ha ha ha!
We're doing it!
We found the perfect center!
We found it!
Can't take it with the super chat.
Thank you.
What?
You don't want pasta and cereal!
What do you mean you don't want pasta and cereal?
It's the perfect combination for your day!
It's literally breakfast, lunch, and dinner!
I give you breakfast, lunch, and dinner!
Ha ha ha ha!
This is a math simulator.
I gave her more than her change?
No!
The pasta is still too expensive!
This is good pasta!
This is...
What do you mean?
Amy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Weirdo, thank you for the five gifted chips.
It's like the good type of pasta!
Yeah!
This man can afford quality life for his children.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Two...
One...
Here you go.
Ha ha ha!
Makes it three nigh- Oh, that's true!
Three ninety-nine.
I'm gonna steal that man's nosey car economics.
Ha ha ha ha!
There you go.
We're good.
Yay!
Seven...
There you go.
We're doing it!
The three ninety-nine is...
We're running a successful store!
Oh my god!
It's really expensive!
You don't deserve the cereal, ma'am!
Come back when you have the money!
For this...
Sick-ass choc- Choccy...
Pick... Bear cereal.
Strong chocolate.
Okay.
Maybe this is a bit too much chocolate.
Ha ha ha ha!
This is...
Better whole foods!
Come back when you can afford to take care of your children with gourmet cereal.
How is that still too expensive?
Okay, what about...
Ninety-eight.
We gotta like oversell to make money!
Five...
Six... One...
There you go.
Easy.
Ha ha ha ha!
Come...
How is that still too expensive?
I don't understand.
I don't extend.
Alright.
My store is not... My store is like...
Good for everybody.
Create more change.
Ha ha ha ha!
Alright.
Okay, how about ninety-seven?
Maybe ninety-seven.
Ninety-five.
We're gonna find a sweet spot.
Alright.
One cent.
There you go.
Oh wait.
You can take your money back but right...
Okay.
That's one dollar.
No.
Okay.
I was gonna be like...
You gave them one dollar.
Ha ha ha ha!
Guys, I'm learning.
I'm learning to be the best cashier.
Why is it still too expensive?
First it was pasta, now it's cereal!
Okay.
Fifty.
It has to be good.
It has to be the sweet spot.
Alright.
Let's see.
How much was it?
Three ninety-nine.
There you go.
Ma'am!
Are you looking for some cereal for your children?
Ah!
That's right.
You know the good life.
Your chi...
This cereal and pasta will make your children so fucking smart.
Trust me.
This is like certified dokey.
Dokey.
Ha ha ha ha!
Ah yes!
Rich lady!
Are you here to make sure your children are eating well?
You don't love your kids.
Ha ha ha ha!
Maybe...
Alright.
We need more pasta.
There you go.
Yay!
Alright.
At least my pasta is selling now.
Yay!
Ha ha ha!
Are they still too expensive?
Do I have lights?
No, we don't need electricity.
I don't want to wait.
Wait.
Okay.
I need to look at the electricity bill.
Do we have to pay electricity bill?
No.
Okay.
Not yet.
I was gonna say...
We can have electricity for now.
I need to know.
I need to know how much electricity is.
Alright.
Fine!
Three... Okay.
Wait.
No.
It was a cereal, right?
Why is cereal so expensive for you?
This is market price!
This is actually market price cereal.
Okay.
Fine.
We're going eight dollars.
Guys.
We're having a cereal sale.
Serious...
Oh, food's in dark mode.
Cereal sale time!
Oh my god!
Look it!
They see a good bargain.
They know that's a good bargain.
3.99.
Nice.
Thank you.
Oh, and you can... Oh, okay.
I thought they gave me exact change.
There you go.
Guys!
Cereal sale!
It's 9pm!
Ha ha ha!
Guys!
We have a great deal for all of you!
Ha ha ha!
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
Be like a real store.
Slap a 50% discount sign.
But... But still sell it at price price!
Profit 10 out of 10!
Also milk and sauce for the cereal and pasta.
Oh my god!
You guys are so fucking smart!
It's like you guys own...
You guys have owned like...
Ha ha ha!
Cereal stores.
Before.
Also give me a sec.
Let me pull up my cereal.
So I can look at Super Chat easier.
Ha ha ha!
Okay.
So I don't have to scroll up for Super Chats real fast.
Alright.
Here we go.
We gotta end the day.
Alright.
Products found.
Expenses 17.
Oh yeah!
I don't need you 17 people!
I have 8 customers!
That can afford my bougie cereal!
They care about their kids!
They care about the well-being of their children!
Income.
I have a $56 profit!
Yay!
Thank you for the Super Chat!
Thank you!
Oh man!
If I stepped in this shop with this selection, I will feel bad not buying anything!
Exactly!
Ha ha ha!
No receipt date?
Nooooo!
Or they'll be paid automatically?
Exactly!
The more electrical devices...
What if I don't turn the lights on?
I'll just never turn on the lights!
That's fucked up!
That's so fucked up!
I'll just never turn on the lights!
So I'll never have to pay bills!
Ha ha ha!
If there's no electricity!
Okay.
We need bread.
Now people would want bread with their food.
Bread...
and oil to cook pasta.
There we go.
We're going... doing it.
Alright.
Let's see.
Wait.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oil.
Alright.
Now we have oil for the pasta!
We love pasta with just oil!
And then...
Bread!
Oh shit.
Um...
Bread!
Alright.
This is good shelving right there.
You know what?
No, no, no, no, no.
This is... This is optimal shelving.
Alright.
Let's see.
What's the market price for bread?
$3.96.
$5.
This is like...
bread made by one baker in a small village in Italy.
That's when you know it's good bread.
Oh!
$5.99!
So it looks cheaper.
$5.99.
Ha ha ha!
Oil!
Alright.
$4.50 is the market price.
$6.99.
There we go.
That's good.
That's good bread.
This bread!
This bread, chat, was made by an 80 year old grandma in Italy.
That's when you know it's good bread.
Ha ha ha!
This oil is peanut oil from the forest of Madagascar.
That's when you know it's good peanut oil.
And we're open for business.
If you don't buy any of my products, you don't love your children enough.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Conserving energy like this is five nights at Doki's.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It is imported!
How dare you call me a scammer!
This is imported peanut oil from Madagascar!
Ha ha ha!
That's a supermarket slogan.
I can get bought.
It's like I'll take ten dollars worth of bread, please.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ha ha ha!
Sir!
How dare you not love your children!
Ha ha ha!
You only give them pasta without the oil?
What is wrong with you?
Ha ha ha!
I can't...
This by the way, the grandma's name is Bron, by the way.
Ha ha ha!
I can't believe it!
Why would grandma... What the fuck?
Bro, carry some fucking change.
What's wrong with you?
Alright, here you go.
Alright.
Who carries cash anymore?
Okay, fine.
Grandma Ron will not be happy about this.
Ha ha ha!
Grandma...
You don't really say is Madagascar a movie?
It's based off a play!
Ha ha ha!
Madagascar is an actual place.
It's an actual country.
Okay.
Thirteen point five.
Alright.
There you go.
This woman loves their children enough.
Alright.
Guys!
Guys, buy my...
Oh my god!
My... Okay, wait, wait.
We need to order more... We need to order more cereal.
Our cereal is actually going off the shelves right now.
Alright.
Boop boop.
Okay.
Oh.
Nice.
No change.
Card.
Alright.
Eight dollars.
Nice.
Okay, we gotta restock our cereal.
Boop boop.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
One cereal, please.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ivy, thank you for the super chat.
Doki's Whole Foods model.
If you don't buy my products, you don't love your children.
Exactly!
This is like... These products, these imported bread and oil, it will make your kids so fucking smart.
Okay, four... fifty.
There's a fifty cents now?
When the fuck was there a fifty cents?
Has there always been a fifty... Wait, what did he say was too expensive?
What did he say?
When you don't have kids, then you're not thinking about your future.
Don't you...
I...
You need to have kids so you can buy my products.
Have children so they can buy my products!
And also subscribe to me on the YouTube.
That is important.
Okay, one cereal.
Thank you for buying my stuff.
Bread is bread.
Here's ten more dollars to take it back.
Oil is too expensive?
Okay.
Okay, fine.
We'll do six dollars.
Are you happy now?
Are you happy now, Janice?
Are you fucking happy now?
I have to pay rent!
Okay?
Doki's Whole Food needs to survive.
Are you happy about ruining small business?
You're the reason why small businesses don't prosper.
Okay.
Let's see.
19.99 Oh my god!
You love your children!
Sir, I'm so happy for you.
Guys!
This is...
Guys, guys.
Support local businesses.
Please.
Guys, I'm almost done with my objective.
Please buy my stuff.
Buy my products.
This is so fucked.
Imagine like a store manager.
Just be like, please buy my products.
Please.
You look like a lady who needs cereal.
Do you need some cereal, ma'am?
Oh my god!
She bought two bread!
And it's oil!
Oh my god!
She's gonna make a grilled cheese!
Alright, nice.
Okay, money.
Oh, and she pays an exact change.
I love her.
I love what every business wants.
Wings, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Treating kids like a Costco membership.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
One, two, three.
Ta-da!
I'm making so much money now!
Look at me!
I have a hundred and sixty-four dollars!
She love her kids.
Alright, nice.
Eight dollars.
Oh my god, I'm getting better at math.
Oil is too expensive.
You are never meant to be in my store.
Oh, but you bought two cereals, so that's okay.
That's more money.
Nevermind.
Welcome back, sir.
I hope you enjoy your stay.
Purchase product license?
For what?
What do I need product license for?
I have everything I've ever wanted.
Cereal, bread, and pasta.
And oil.
Extreme, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm sorry.
I was trying to get the pickles, but I accidentally locked it over the pickle display in aisle six.
But I'm covered in pickle juice, and the entire store smells like pickles.
I hope this covers the cost.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You can't afford my pasta!
Go back and buy macaroni and cheese!
Which I love macaroni and cheese, by the way.
No hate on macaroni and cheese.
But this is bougie pasta.
Alright, we're not turning on the lights because I need to save save electricity.
Uh, I need...
Guys!
We need to save electricity!
We don't need lights!
We don't need lights, guys!
Guys, this is important.
We are a small local business.
What do you think?
You think we're actual Whole Foods?
We're not!
We're better Whole Foods, but we're not the better yet.
Okay.
Wait, I'm so poor.
I can't afford any product license.
My favorite grilled cheese without the cheese.
It's okay.
I can defend my store in the dark.
Alright, nice.
What do you... Okay, cash.
One dollar.
Ooh, I like you, sir.
Nice.
Alright.
Card.
Um... Six dollars.
We're Half Foods!
We're not at the Whole Foods section yet, guys.
We're merely in the Half Foods section.
One day, we'll be like Whole Foods.
A hundred dollar profit!
Nice!
Alright.
Nice.
Do I have to pay any bills yet?
Bank.
Okay, no.
We're not getting a loan.
Management.
Bills.
But see!
Look at that!
Look at that, chat!
I didn't turn on the lights I didn't turn on the lights and only 52 cents!
That is how you spend money.
That is exactly how you save money.
Why use lights?
My phone can produce lights.
Guys, my phone produces light.
So, why the fuck would I need any electricity?
If I can't see anything, I take out my phone.
Sounds like my dad.
It is called being a small business trying to survive in the harsh world.
Okay, do I need...
I don't have the level yet.
Alright.
Oh, we need to restock.
We need to restock on our imported peanut oil.
Alright.
Where is product?
Oops.
Okay.
Oil.
Alright.
We just need oil.
That's fine.
Yes, Mr. Krabs.
Thank you.
Yeah!
But Mr. Krabs is a fucking millionaire!
Look!
I will be...
Mr. Krabs is a role model!
He is a cutthroat business crab!
He knows what it's like...
He has a whale daughter to fucking care for.
Do you know how much whales eat?
Okay, let's see.
Sixteen dollars.
Whales eat a lot of food!
And then he has to pay for college tuition!
I like money!
He likes money!
We all like money here.
God, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
We need cereal.
We need a picture for the cereal demand.
Don't worry!
I will make sure that the demand is met.
Oh my god.
No, ma'am!
Do not buy anything!
The cereal is coming!
Okay.
There we go.
Nice.
Alright.
Wait, she didn't buy anything.
What?
You don't love your children?
You don't love your kids?
What's your husband gonna think?
Oh my god.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't keep your ass remember her first dollar.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Let's see.
Six.
Alright.
I can't believe it.
You're willing to buy expensive bread but not expensive cereal.
Oh my god.
This bread is more expensive than the fucking cereal.
Like, what the fuck is...
Actually, never mind.
Five dollar profit.
Oh yeah.
Super.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat as well Okay, there's no chance in hell Pearl is smart enough for a scholarship.
That's right.
I said it.
There's no way Pearl can have a...
Can get a scholarship.
That's fucking right.
She has to be able to afford her college.
Don't do it like that!
What?
How is she gonna get to college?
The cheerleading?
Oh yeah, as if like... yeah, yeah.
There's like how many people in Bikini Bottom?
How many people in Bikini Bottom?
I don't think they're giving out scholarships for a fucking cheerleading.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
1-0 please keep the cheerleading going.
That is a good customer.
Hello, would you like to give a tip for a small business woman?
For your local businesses?
I don't have a tip jar.
I should have a tip jar.
Whole Foods might not have a tip jar, but Half Foods does.
Oh, $212!
I'm level 13!
Oh, I'm level 3!
I can buy a product.
Okay, what can I sell?
Bottled water!
Guys, guys.
Evian water is coming in hot now.
Guys.
Oh my god, this is it!
We're in the big leagues now!
We have bottled water!
We're moving up!
We're not just gonna be Half Foods!
Okay, how much is bottled water?
Okay, bottled water is $15.
I can afford bottled water!
Oh my god, we're actually in the big leagues.
Oh my god, we have water!
Boop.
Wait.
This product... wait, what?
I need to be put on a fridge?
God damn it.
Okay, guys.
We're not in the big leagues yet.
I can't afford a fridge.
That's like electricity!
Who wants cold water?
Put it in the fridge yourself!
Who the fuck wants cold water?
I don't understand.
Okay, we need more bread.
We need to sell... Room temperature water is just fine!
Room temperature water is good enough.
Oh shit, incorrect payment.
Who cares?
Okay, 5.5.
Nice.
Okay, boop.
Card?
Nice.
Card is nice, because I don't have to worry about...
Uh...
Alright, I don't have to worry about math.
I can just put numbers down.
Okay, cereal, bread.
I don't... I can't afford a fridge!
What do you mean?
Fridge?
It's $200?!
Oh my god!
I'm not made of money!
Okay.
Thirty... two... fifty.
Cereal.
A name started taking the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Remind that Mr. Krabs make Spongebob pay to work at the Krusty Krab.
Oh my god!
Guys, who wants to work at...
For one Akasupa, you can have the privilege to work in my store for a day.
It's like an internship, guys.
Think about like the amazing reference I can work... I can write for you.
Guys, just think about it.
Think about the amazing reference you're gonna get.
If you work at Half Foods.
What a deal!
Also, it's like one Aka a day, though, by the way.
It's one Aka a day.
Just so you guys know.
Um...
Zalphius, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Who wants Evian water when you can buy locally sourced Evian tap water bottle by the local kids for free?
Only $100.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, Zalphius.
Now somebody is thanking.
What do you think about my business?
That's a good business owner right there.
3.99.
Here we go.
This is the night time experience.
The only store that's in the dark.
We have to save on electricity.
We are not made of money.
The only reason we're in the dark is because it's your fault, customers.
You don't pay...
I'm here for my shift.
Oh, thank God.
Alright, so anyway, I'll just be like the supervisor now.
What?
Minus 84 profit?
Oh my God.
Thank God for my free interns.
I need the references for my resume.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God for my free interns.
Oh, I don't have enough for anything.
Okay, we need more oil.
Alright, oil.
There we go.
Purchase.
Uh, Lori Tanda, thank you for the Akasuba.
Thank you, thank you.
So when is my first day?
Right now, stock these shows for me.
I wish this has like, if only this has like Twitch plays, Supermarket Simulator, so I can like actually hire my...
Viewers.
You know like those, like the call of the lamb where you can get viewer participation?
Man, if only I could get viewer participation.
The multiplayer store already.
And I could just sit here and order items.
Oh shit, what are the biz?
Do I have to pay any biz?
Biz.
Rent?
I paid for rent!
$20 a day?
That's like a scam!
I'm just a small business!
The $20 is like one peanut oil.
Oh my God.
Hahaha.
Boom, thank you for the Akasuba!
Thank you, thank you.
Do we get cool name tags?
Guys, with enough Akas, we can afford one cashier.
Guys, you see, daily wage is...
You guys pay me $80.
Guys, with enough Akas, we can finally afford a cashier!
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh, we need pasta.
Pasta!
Where's pasta?
Alright, pasta.
Guys, I need $200, guys.
Please.
$14.
Four.
Oh, whoops.
Nice.
I can leave 50 checkouts!
Oh my gosh, I'm doing it.
I'm being the wagey I've always wanted to be.
Where's my pasta?
Okay, pasta.
Alright.
We don't care about your fucking opinion.
Annie.
You spent less on that fucking...
You spent less on...
Okay, you clearly need sunscreen.
You spent less at the hair salon.
Maybe you can afford Granny Ron's bread.
Now your family's gonna be breadless.
You can clearly afford fucking bread.
If you only have $100 bills, you can totally afford bread.
Okay?
You're just a cheapskate.
I hope your kids hate you.
Alright, card.
Nice.
She gave you $100.
Alright, nice.
$160.
Guys, I need $100!
Anybody wanna shop and have food?
Whoa!
Look.
Chat, you don't understand.
This supermarket game is very scary.
This supermarket game is very intense, guys.
You don't understand.
Okay?
You'll never understand the life of a supermarket boner.
Okay, calm down.
I can't calm down!
She criticized my pasta and bread!
That grandma in Italy needs that money!
Okay.
I'm counting.
Intensifies.
Guys!
Think about Granny Ron!
Won't anybody think about Granny Ron from Italy?
She cares about Granny Ron!
She cares so much about her Granny Ron.
She gave me $250.
Nice.
Okay.
Alright.
Five, six, seven, eight, nine.
There you go.
Thank you for shopping at Half Foods.
Ron's sliced bread is too expensive.
What did you buy?
You buy two cereals and zero bread?
It's like almost the same.
It's almost the same.
Put in some checkout count and you won't even have to pay.
Oh my God!
Frank, you're so smart.
We can let techno...
AI can finally steal everybody's work.
Oh my God!
Finally, the AI uprising we needed.
They started out small.
First the checkout cashiers.
Then the world.
The Walmart approach.
It's actually scary though.
Now there's some McDonald's that are only run by self checkout.
Everything is just automated.
I remember reading an article about that.
That there's McDonald's restaurants that are just fully automated.
Even taking orders and everything.
Yeah, like making food and taking orders and giving orders and stuff.
I don't know.
I think it has to be in America.
Only somebody in America would do something like that.
Oh, my cereal!
Everybody loves cereal.
Okay.
Alright.
Grab that cereal.
Someone's like, we have those in New York City.
They suck.
Money.
50 cents.
There you go.
You love bread.
Thank you for supporting your local granny.
$31.
Nice.
I can't wait for the AI takeover.
It gives me more time.
Cam.
You have all the time.
But where the money to you?
To you.
Cam, you forgot.
The money.
If all the robots take over all the jobs, how do we make money?
Yeah.
Who would give you the money to keep working?
That's not keep working.
To do whatever you want.
Alright.
Nice.
Where's the tomatoes?
Tomatoes cost a fridge.
Does it look like I have the money for fridge?
Okay.
We need more.
Nice.
I can finally afford.
I can afford a fridge.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Fridge time.
Fridge A.
Alright.
$200.
Yeah.
Okay.
Where's my fridge?
Oh my god.
Sir, please wait a little bit.
I'm putting a fridge.
Okay.
Nice.
Exact bills.
I love that.
One bill.
$200.
Nice.
Okay.
We can finally put our expensive avian water.
Yay!
Alright.
What do you want?
Would you like to buy our expensive avian water real fast before you do?
No?
It's alright.
Alright.
Where's my water?
Okay.
How much for water?
Two.
Five dollars.
This is like $200.
This is not Amazon 99 cents.
Shit.
Oh no.
No.
Not zero dollars.
Oh, there's more people coming in.
Oh, nice.
Uh...
27.
Sorry.
I couldn't see that you used your card.
Did you buy water?
Was water too expensive?
Oh, you don't want basic necessities?
Sir?
That's Fiji water right there.
That's not regular water.
This is from a fucking island.
I think five dollars is perfect.
What a deal.
Nuki, stop.
Sir, it's good water, sir.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Nuki, I need you to do a Costco livestream ASAP.
I'm sorry.
I need a stream of you walking around Costco and picking out your favorite Gurtland products.
Costco sponsor.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, it's because I bought a fridge.
Okay.
I had to...
I need a...
Okay, you know what?
I'm going to make my entire fridge just... just water.
This is...
Okay, no.
Water and milk.
Wait.
Okay.
What do you guys...
I'm going to make my entire fridge just...
just water.
Okay.
Cheese!
Cheese for the pasta!
This is it.
Now we're thinking supermarket owner.
Cheese for the pasta.
Wait, we're running out of stuff.
Wait.
Okay.
Uh...
We need pasta.
Okay, let's just stock up everything for now.
We have the money.
All right.
If we have everything we need to stock up, we don't have to worry about anything.
Okay, we're going to put this away.
Oh my gosh.
Our store is...
Our store is becoming so big now!
We're getting closer to closer to like, uh, three fourths of food.
Okay.
What's after half foods?
Two quarters food?
What's after half foods, guys?
I'll put cheese.
It needs to be in the fridge.
God damn it.
We don't want cold cheese.
Food temperature.
Room temperature cheese is okay.
Guys.
Sometimes you have to settle.
Sometimes you can settle for...
Oh, I'm too poor for eggs.
I'm too poor for eggs.
Okay, I can't afford milk though.
All right.
We're gonna fully stock up.
It'll get mulled?
That's the point of cheese!
Good cheese has mold!
This is why this is called...
This is half foods.
You guys don't understand.
Okay.
Good cheese has mold.
Doki, no.
You just don't understand good marketing.
Doki, please.
All right.
Nice.
We're open.
I forgot to buy oil.
I can't afford oil.
No!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't have...
I don't have any oil.
I don't have enough money for tomatoes!
Look!
I can only do...
There's cake.
There's chicken.
Where the fuck is the fruit section?
There's cleaner chips.
There's beer.
Oh my god.
Guys, we need 3,500.
Guys!
Why can't the bank give me a loan for beer?
There's books, but there's no fruit?
What is my store?
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
$16.
All right.
Money.
Oh.
Okay.
Eight.
We're getting better at this.
We're getting...
Oh god.
Okay.
I can afford oil now.
Uh...
Oil.
Nice.
Okay.
This is good.
Oh no!
Wrong...
Wrong shelf.
Wait.
What shelf was it?
Is it this one?
Okay.
I need a better shelving system.
Why me?
Guys, I need a better shelving system.
I already forgot where it was.
Guys!
Guys, does anyone want to shop?
Oh my god.
You have money.
You're wearing a tuxedo.
You want mine?
The peanut oil?
Look.
Hey.
This is new here.
Cheese is too expensive!
Water is too expensive!
God.
Okay.
4.99.
There we go.
They don't know.
They're not cultured enough.
Okay.
We're putting 99.
There we go.
Why is my water so expensive?
It's from an island!
It's literally from an island!
Where are my, like...
Where are my, like, Jack Blacks and Tom Hanks?
Where are they?
They can afford my water.
They care.
Alright.
4.50.
Fine!
I'll go 4.50, but that's the lowest I'll pay.
That's the lowest I'll go.
$4.50.
I'll take the $2 profit.
Round Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I will never change the oil.
My peanut oil from Madagascar.
It has too deep and bitter of a flavor.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
$4.49.
You're right.
When they see the 9, they know it's a steal.
$4.49.
Oh my god.
You guys are good business people.
Good business goons.
Milk is too expensive?
Oh my god.
Why is everything too expensive for all of you?
If you guys think everything is too expensive, you would not have gone to Half Foods.
Whole Foods is like right next door.
You know what you were expecting in Half Foods.
It might not have been a good business choice to be right next to Whole Foods.
But...
But it was the cheapest place to rent.
$3.48.
God damn it.
Fine.
I'll go down to $4.2.
I'm willing to haggle.
It's $4.2 now.
Welcome to Quarter Foods.
Guys.
Guys, you'll regret this.
I'll remember all your faces.
You'll regret not buying from my store when I become big.
See?
She likes the cheese.
Okay.
$95.
Jesus Christ.
She likes the cheese too.
If you love cheese so much, why didn't you buy more?
Please.
Support your local businesses.
Fine.
$0.10.
The lowest I'll go.
Haha.
It doesn't even have mud.
Because they won't let me put it in room temperature.
I can't believe it.
Wait.
Do I have to pay my bills?
I might have forgotten about my bills.
Bills.
Oh shit.
Oh, 0.49.
Nice.
Okay.
$20.
Alright.
That's fine.
Nice.
Do you like my water?
Is bottled water good enough?
Is it good enough?
Oh, it's good enough.
Enough.
Come on.
Couldn't find... What do you mean you want coffee?
Ma'am!
We don't have a lot of things in the store.
Okay, four.
Nice.
Alright, what do you want?
Ooh, cereal and pasta?
You're gonna have a fun night, sir.
It's gonna be so fun.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
Fine.
I am willing to go $5.99 on the oil.
My distributors are not gonna be happy about this.
But I'm willing to go for this bargain.
Alright.
We're having a sale!
Guys!
An oil sale!
Grab your oils!
Never before seen!
Such a deal.
Never before seen oil sale before!
Grab it before it's gone!
Someone say oil?
Nice.
I'm glad this person...
Oh, look at that.
He heard about the sale.
He heard about the oil sale.
Good for you.
Why is my water always too expensive?
I don't understand.
This is like, perfect.
It's like, specifically priced water.
Okay.
$4.10.
That's the lowest I'll go, with cheese.
For my imported from France cheese.
Alright, hello ma'am.
Sliced bread.
You don't deserve raw and sliced bread.
You don't deserve.
You can't- You don't deserve to be at my store and never come back!
Hello.
Oh my god, he heard about the oil sale.
So where did you hear about the oil sale?
So, from your family, friends, website sponsors, Facebook...
We don't need lighting!
We don't need it!
We're here to save money!
We need to save money to make money!
This is like an exclusive experience that you can only get at Half Foods.
Whole Foods is wasting... Imagine all the electricity Whole Foods is wasting right now by turning on their lights.
Oh my god!
Guys!
I told you!
Tell your friends!
Our oil is one cent cheaper!
One cent is all it took.
It truly is.
Oh, whoops.
Ninety... Oh!
There.
Nice.
We did it.
I almost said...
Hey!
If it works, it works, guys!
Look at that!
And now look at that profit!
A hundred and fourteen!
I don't want to lose it.
Oh, eggs are now...
worse now.
That's okay.
We don't need eggs anyway.
We need more oil.
These are the eggs.
This is the oil... This is the oil boom, guys.
The oil boom.
It's rising.
Oh, back in you go.
Twenty-two.
We don't care!
Those twenty-two people!
They don't matter.
We're here to build a customer base that can afford my products.
Okay.
Let's see.
We're gonna grab...
We're gonna grab some flour.
Um...
For the... I guess like the cereal.
We love putting flour on the cereal.
Alright.
Let's put them up here.
This should be good.
And then we're gonna put that away.
Alright.
How much should the flour be?
Okay.
Five dollars.
Is that good profit?
That's a good profit.
Okay.
Four ninety-nine.
Four point ninety-nine.
There you go.
So now you know it's a good...
No, no!
I'm gonna put five dollars!
And then I'm gonna lower it to...
And then I'm gonna lower it to four ninety-nine.
So then they'll think it's a sale.
They'll be like, damn that flour is too expensive.
And I'll be like...
I'll be like, oh my god!
Good thing for you!
We have a sale going on now.
We have a sale going on.
Now every flour is four ninety...
Hey, if it worked for oil, it can work for flour.
It's not mutually exclusive.
Come.
Come to my store.
Uh, YT, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm an oil man.
Don't keep playing with you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Ma'am, have you heard about our oil sale?
Ma'am?
Are you gonna buy the... We have zero purchases on the water.
Ma'am, it's literally three ninety-nine!
Don't you need all milk?
Can I suggest you, um...
People who buy the milk also bought the cereal.
Would you like to have this in the cart?
Ha ha ha ha!
Um...
So I was thinking for the super chat.
Thank you.
Welcome to the tomato... tomato farm.
Welcome.
Forty...
Four... Okay, no.
One, two, three, four, fifty...
Amazon recommendation.
Amazon and Uber Eats recommendation.
Four point one.
There we go.
Gotta pay the bills later.
Ma'am!
Where you at?
The cereal?
Ma'am, you know what's cheaper?
Milk.
Would you like the milk?
Oh, the cheese?
Oh, you're a cheese girl.
I see.
What the fuck were you gonna do with cereal and cheese?
I'll never know.
Okay.
Oh, and you play exact.
You clearly only had budget for cheese.
Uh, we need more cheese.
It's working, guys.
One day somebody will buy my water.
Oh my god!
It's working!
It's the cheese boom!
Yes, guys, you gotta... Quick, quick, guys!
Oil is yesterday's news.
Today is all about the cheese.
Two dollar.
Hello, sir.
Milk?
Okay.
Okay, I need to...
Guys, I've been holding onto this water for two days now.
I don't understand why people do not want...
Okay, what about 3.59?
There we go.
Someone's... Please!
It's a basic necessity!
Please purchase your water!
Sir, are you gonna buy water?
Please, why?
Please!
I know it's the cheese boom, sir!
Why is water so too expensive?
Fine!
Three dollars!
That's my final price.
I can't believe it.
Why has no one won my water?
Water is... is like...
Like, you don't need milk.
Guys, you don't need cheese!
You know?
You don't need cheese!
It's because of...
No, not the sunny.
No.
Not the sunny cheese.
Not the sunny water.
One cent.
Here you go.
Water?
Would you like...
Oh my god!
Wait, did he buy cheese?
He bought cheese.
Never mind.
He did not... Guys, he did not buy water.
He did not buy water.
Okay, 20.9.
One.
Yay!
We got 26 dollars!
Wait, what am I gonna save for now?
Okay.
We can clearly buy...
Um...
Okay, I'm gonna...
How much is... Okay, checkout counter, spotlight...
Okay, I wanna be able to afford a cashier.
Give me a sec!
Oh my god!
Can't you be patient?
I'm trying to see if I can afford a...
a worker.
Okay.
Biz 490.
I need to be level 10?
I'm just level 5!
Okay, we need...
Level 10?
Okay, we can afford this.
Warren, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
To be fair...
You are a cheese skate for that price of water?
This is reasonably priced water!
Guys!
I say as I...
uncap my Fiji water right now...
Thank you!
Oh!
All I had to do...
was drink Fiji water in front of my water fridge!
That's all I had to do!
I figured it out!
There you go.
I figured it out.
Guys!
84.
Okay.
1, 2, 3, 4.
1, 2.
There you go.
Okay, we need more.
We need flour!
Please give me a sec, ma'am!
We need...
flour!
Pasta!
Okay.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Okay, $21.
Please!
I need to...
restock my store!
Pasta!
Pasta's good!
I'm going off the shelves right now!
We're making so much money off of pasta!
And then flour.
Alright.
Nice, alright.
I'll never lower my prices.
You can't make me.
Except for water.
I'll do that for wine!
Guys, my water has been in the store a little bit too long now.
Okay, where's the card?
Okay, grab the card.
Hahaha!
Guys, I will figure out how... I will have night vision soon.
Eventually, I'll unlock night vision.
No!
I need to save money!
Hahaha!
I will never turn on the lights.
My customers clearly are fine with it.
They're fine.
It's like immersive.
Also, using your card for a purchase for $4 is dumb.
Because there's hidden fees and stuff.
Hahaha!
I don't like using my cards for stuff that's less than $10 because of the fees you can get from that.
Nice!
$182!
That's right.
I know you guys were yelling at me to lower my prices.
But look at the money I made from that.
Oh, cheese.
Cheese is flying off the shelves right now.
Cheese, pasta, okay, we have enough.
Alright, here you go.
Uhhh... nice.
Alright, cheese.
Cheese!
We don't need... oh wait.
We can... uh...
I can't throw.
I'm gonna put the cheese here.
We have enough oil.
We need cereal.
We need... we started off with cereal.
Our cereal is our biggest money maker.
Cereal and oil.
Alright.
Let's see.
I think we're ready.
We're ready.
No, I'm gonna order more pasta.
Pasta's been doing well too.
Pasta time.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna make my first $1000.
This is it, guys.
Where were you when...
Yuki made her first $1000.
We're...
Double...
Thank you.
Geez, the people that come in after sundown be struggling to see those shows.
That's good!
That means they don't know what they're paying for.
It's like a little game.
It's like a little game, guys.
They don't know what they're paying for.
So it's like more fun.
It's... guys, it's more fun.
It's like a...
And like maybe they'll accidentally, you know, they'll accidentally pay... buy more than they actually wanted, you know?
Alright, milk time.
Okay, $7.98.
There you go.
How much should I...
Okay, market is... okay, then that is $12.
Nice.
Alright.
Hello, ma'am.
Did you enjoy your stay here at Half Foods?
Uh...
$75...
$85.
There you go.
That's fine.
It's too expensive?
It's literally at $5...
Okay, wait.
Maybe if I do $11.99.
Guys!
Coffee on sale!
We're having our biggest sale yet, everybody!
Four... two...
Oh.
Biggest sale yet!
...
More than 1% off!
Guys!
...
Great value!
We need milk.
Milk time.
...
Okay.
Uh...
Nice.
Okay, we need restock.
We need restock.
Good.
...
We got...
Yeah!
Biggest sale.
...
We got...
Well...
Guys, I don't understand.
Why does anyone want my coffee?
There's a huge sale going on.
Guys!
Big sale!
We're now 5% off!
Tell your friends!
Use this coupon!
Tell your friends, everybody!
Big sale!
Do you want the coffee?
Guys, are you here for the...
Are you here for the coffee?
At least my milk and cheese is doing good.
82 cents.
There you go.
I eventually got there.
Oh, thank god.
At least my water is doing great.
My water and cheese.
80 cents.
Yeah.
Yay!
Oh, oil!
The oil boom.
It's working.
Okay.
Alright, putting that away.
Oh my god!
I knew it!
Sir, you look like a person that knows your coffee!
Hahaha!
You look like a man that loves coffee!
My man!
That's my man right there.
Nice.
Okay, we gotta get rid of that.
And then...
Cheese.
Alright, putting that away.
Sir, are you here for your cereal and water?
Sir!
You're one of those people.
Hahaha!
Cereal and water people.
Oh no!
He's one of them.
Okay.
Let's see.
11.98.
Yay!
Oh my god!
We're actually running out of water for once!
Cheese time.
Alright, 4.1.
Bread.
89.
There you go.
Okay, bread time.
Wait, do we need more?
What do we need more?
Water, cheese.
We always need water and cheese.
We'll order water and cheese first.
And then...
Okay, cheese time.
And then we'll put...
Yeah, now I can put my cheese on the floor.
That's okay!
But, oh!
Oh, I can't sell my cheese on the shelf?
That's so dumb.
No, I can be like...
I can like not change my prices.
And just be like 50% off.
Guys!
Everything is 50% off!
From the original prices!
Guys!
I think I saw that in Apex.
Where they did like...
They did like a huge sale.
And then they crossed the numbers out.
And it was the same price.
I could do that.
This sale is gonna end...
In 5 minutes and 30 seconds...
If you don't act quick, guys!
There you go.
Alright, water and milk.
Are you paying my cash?
There you go.
Cheese is too expensive?
Everybody else liked my cheese.
You're the only person that didn't like the cheese.
Don't keep paying your bills.
I don't need to pay my bills.
I need to pay my bills.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It would be even better if you don't show the price at all.
And randomize it as checkout.
Got your food to be an instant.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Where's the money?
Oh, there's your card.
Okay.
Sorry.
Sorry, my night vision hasn't kicked in yet.
Alright.
38...
8.50.
There you go.
One oil?
That's fine by me.
5.99.
Nice.
Look at that.
We're doing so good.
The Genshin market.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You have a cute laugh.
I'm glad you've been enjoying it.
$118 profit.
Look at that.
We're almost at $500.
Milk is up!
Milk and eggs are up!
Wait.
How do I do this?
Milk and...
Okay.
Unit price.
Milk.
Okay.
I can be more expensive with milk now.
It went up by how much?
How much did it go up by?
1.20.
So that means I can technically sell.
Sell it for...
$4.99.
I sell for $4.99 now.
Okay.
Good.
Now we need cereal and bread.
Okay.
Cereal...
and bread.
Our OG money makers.
Oh my god.
Milk stocks are going up guys.
Where were you guys?
We're going to the moon!
I can't believe it.
I can't believe the milk stock.
It's rising.
Okay.
Where's my cheese?
Only one person bought my cheese.
Alright.
We're opening!
Ding ding ding!
Open time!
I'm saving up for a cashier right now.
Okay.
Let's see.
We can...
We can buy tea.
That's fine.
Alright.
That's like...
Can we show down here, right?
Yeah.
Tea next to the coffee.
That should make sense.
Nice.
Alright.
Tea...
And then...
We're going to make it $6.
$6.32.
$7.
$8.
Where's $8?
There you go.
$4.99 profit.
That should be good profit.
We're open!
I am here to...
Wait.
Can I like explore the place?
Oh, I can.
But I shouldn't.
No!
Please!
I'm sorry!
I shouldn't explore.
We don't have a cashier.
Nice.
Thank you.
$5.99.
Thank you, sir, for supporting your local business.
Thank you.
More balls!
Thank you for the 20 gift-a-shifts!
Thank you!
Ma'am, are you here?
Oh my god!
You have a big family, ma'am!
Oh!
Thank you.
The store...
The store is happy for your service.
Oh my god!
Pasta night?
Is it pasta night tonight for you?
Okay.
Let's see.
$4.
$3.
Ma'am.
Let's see.
Milk!
Oh!
You heard about the milk boom!
Don't worry.
Our cows are all raised at a nice, humane farm.
We...
We make sure... We make sure they're fed premium grass!
That's why... That's why the milk boom is going up!
Let's see.
Oil... Oh!
We're running out of coffee.
We're running out of coffee for the businessmen.
Okay.
Coffee.
This is some expensive fucking coffee, but it's okay.
Our cows!
Our cows live the good life!
Okay, guys?
We have good cows!
Oh, ma'am!
Thank you for taking that water.
Now I can stock this.
Alright.
Just one bottle of water?
No problem.
$47?
What the fuck are you doing with your life?
Alright.
$20... $25...
There you go.
At least I don't have to... Oh my god!
That's a lot of caffeine there!
Sir, are you okay?
Is your life okay?
Are you going through some crunch work?
It's too... Oh!
You can afford the coffee, but not the tea?
I see how it is.
Cooking is a hobby.
Okay?
Baking.
Sorry, not cooking.
Baking is a nice hobby.
You can't afford baking.
Because you have no joy in your life.
If you love having joy, you would invest in baking.
Also, thank you for shopping at Half Foods.
Please come again.
Please.
Alright.
Here you go.
What was that?
Sorry, I meant baking.
Cooking is a good skill.
Dad!
The clerk that would avoid at all costs.
You can't avoid me!
I'm the manager!
It's too bad!
I run this store.
You know what you're getting.
The milk is too expensive?
Have you not heard about the milk boom?
I'm joking.
Alright, nice.
How are you going to make pasta without the milk?
What about the cream sauce?
Oil.
My biggest.
Oil, you'll never fail me.
You'll never disappoint me, oil.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Don't regret the day when Half Foods become two-thirds goods.
Don't regret it.
Don't regret pissing me off!
Alright, Sir, thank you.
Thank you for shopping at Half Foods.
27.50 27.50 Oh, ma'am, would you like a little discount?
We're having a sale right now.
0% off.
Don't worry.
Oh, would you all join the membership?
I forgot about the membership!
Ma'am!
To collect points!
Every purchase you get, one point!
It doesn't matter how much you buy!
If you raise enough points, you get a shopping bag!
What about donations?
The doki points!
Wait, what was on top?
Was it flour?
Oh my god, we finally ran out of flour.
It took so long because my flour is a little bit overpriced.
But just a little bit.
It's worth it.
If you love to cook, it's worth it.
You love to bake, I mean.
Alright, nice.
100.00 Exactly!
If you get 100 points, you get 0.01 discount.
Let's see.
92.
Alright.
Coffee!
This woman needs it.
It's too expensive.
What?
You're gonna have oil?
You're gonna hurt yourself!
The food is gonna stick to your pan if you don't buy my oil!
Alright.
16.18 Thank you.
Ma'am, would you like to kindly donate $5 to the charity for dogs?
Would you, ma'am?
Also, would you like to join our membership?
Each point, each purchase equals one point.
And when you collect a thousand points, you can have a 0.1 discount!
I don't think she wants to join my membership, guys.
I don't...
Don't forget!
Sir, would you like to like...
Would you like to give some money in the tip jar, sir?
Our shopkeepers are paid by tips only.
I'm the only employee.
Are you...
TG, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Are you willing to round your spend to $10 to help your local tomato farm?
Sir, would you like to do that?
Would you like to round your purchase up?
Would you like to round your purchase up to $20?
To help your local doki?
It's only $5 more.
Didn't think of the super chat.
TG, thank you.
I'm surprised none of the boxes outside gets stolen.
Cause I will know where they live.
They know I'm crazy cause I open right next to the Whole Foods down the lane.
They don't want to piss off the manager that opened a competing store that's more expensive than Whole Foods.
Alright, nice.
Okay, card.
22.47 Did I run out of cheese?
I can't tell cause it's dark.
But it saves money.
No, at the close?
Wait, is there anybody here?
I can't tell.
There's nobody here, right?
Yeah, there's nobody here.
Sorry.
I'm like a blind moron.
I have to touch everything to know if anybody's here.
Okay, we need cheese and milk.
Oh, there's a cheese boom!
Oh my god.
The cheese boom market is here.
This is everything I've been waiting for.
I knew it was gonna show up!
The cheese boom!
We've been preparing for this, guys!
We've been preparing for this right moment!
Just put the milk here for now.
And then make sure this box of milk doesn't spoil.
The cheese boom!
What is the boom?
Did I buy more cheese?
I bought- I accidentally bought more cheese, but it's okay!
We're prepared for the boom!
Okay.
What- how much is cheese?
2.15?
What was it before?
Wait, what was it before?
How much did it go up by?
Guys!
How much did the cheese go up by?
Hahahaha Hahahaha I don't- I don't remember!
Guys!
Hahahaha The market price was- oh!
4 point- Okay.
Then it'd be- It should be 5 then.
Okay.
5.
Right?
No!
6.
Yeah.
That sounds right.
Hahahaha That sounds right.
$6.00.
Cheese.
Cranberry!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
To be honest, working for Target, they still made us work in the dark when power was out.
And the heat in the heat when our AC went out with no water.
Doki is a great boss.
Oh my god!
Thank god for reminding me!
It's time to turn off the heat as well!
You don't need heat at night!
Guys!
Just open the door!
Hahahaha The- the wind!
The- we don't need heat!
Because we can close the door!
If it's very humid, we can open the door at night!
Hahahaha Or!
Wait, no no no!
Okay, if it's hot, if it's too hot, we open the door so it's cooler with the wind coming in.
If it's winter!
If it's winter, we close the door and like just make sure we don't open the door so the heat will stay in.
And then we- if it's like too hot, we don't need AC.
We just keep the door open.
And then like, um...
at night time, we just keep the door open still.
Hahahaha Hahahaha Hahahaha This is it.
This is- this is genius.
Okay, we gotta...
We gotta buy sugar.
We don't have sugar yet.
Alright, sugar time.
Just bundle up!
We'll give you guys jackets!
Just come into work with more clothes on!
If you're too- too cold.
Guys!
We are a business!
We wanna grow the business, guys.
We're here to grow the business.
Okay, six.
Yeah.
We're here to grow our business!
We need to make sacrifices!
Hahahaha Hahahaha Guys, it's all about sacrifice.
Do you not love half foods?
Do you want Target to win?
Hahahaha Hahahaha Alex, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
One cheese, please.
Guys, I can't believe it.
You are willing to let Target win.
Hahahaha Hahahaha Hahahaha Oh my god.
Guys, you don't want that...
I also don't even know if there's been like... if you guys can even hear the sound.
Have you guys been able to hear the sound this entire time?
The sound of me restocking?
Okay...
No?
You don't hear the So I've been playing?
Yes, it has sound!
Okay!
Oh, shit.
I almost charged this lady $138.
Yes, guys.
This has sound!
Okay, let me turn up the sound real quick.
Okay guys, let's have like supermarket music in.
To be more... you know what, you're right.
We need supermarket music.
We need to be more immersed in our supermarket.
Supermarket music.
There we go.
More sounds of the department store.
Alright, what is this?
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, it's fine.
I can get fucking copyright claimed again.
There we go.
I got copyright claimed for playing Eva Maria.
That's fine.
Here we go.
Does it sound like we're in the supermarket now?
Actually, no.
Maybe not.
Maybe that's not a good idea.
Okay, okay.
Supermarket copyright free.
The church got me, by the way.
Yes, the church actually got me.
They had Jesus actually copyright claim me.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
This is copyright free.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Listen on repeat.
People are gonna go crazy, but it's fine.
We're gonna listen to this on repeat.
We're gonna listen to this on repeat, chat.
Let's see.
Alright.
Here we go.
There we go.
Is this good?
Okay.
There we go.
Hello.
Welcome.
Welcome to half foods.
It feels like we're actually at the supermarket.
Guys, are you not excited?
We get to listen to this.
Yeah!
That's the stuff.
That's the supermarket we've been waiting for.
No, I'm so immersed right now.
Wait, did I not price the milk?
No, that's fine.
The milk prices is fine.
Okay, maybe not.
Okay, maybe...
4.50.
That's the lowest I'll go.
Now we're cooking here.
Now we're actually...
What do you mean it's too expensive?
It's the cheese!
Boom!
Okay, 5.50.
That's the lowest I'll...
I'll go.
Welcome.
I hope you enjoy your experiences here.
Okay, we need to sell...
We need to sell...
This man has my entire flower stock now.
I need to fucking stock this up.
This is the best supermarket!
Your children cannot get lost here!
Do not worry!
Oh, no!
Granberry, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I can't handle the no heat AC!
I can handle the darkness!
But this music is gonna make me go on strike!
I can't take it!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh, we need coffee.
Now we're gonna listen to this for an hour straight.
No, this is reasonably priced milk!
You can't make me lower my milk cost!
Alright,
our goal...
Our goal, guys...
is to get level 10!
And hire...
a minimum wage worker!
To work here forever!
And listen to this every single day!
That is my goal.
I need to hire a minimum wage worker.
To stand here for the rest of their life!
And listen to this two minute repeat.
The worst part is that it's like two minutes repeat too.
That's the worst part of it all.
It's not like...
There's no variety.
It's literally two minutes long.
And it's just going on repeat.
I hate this.
I'm so dead.
Welcome to hell.
Okay, 14.49.
Nice.
Guys, what happened?
Why do you not wanna...
find cheese?
It's the cheese boom!
The cheese boom!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Kaz, a trip to hell was never this cheap.
Only at...
Hello?
It is Half Foods.
Not Doki Marts.
Doki Marts is down the street.
It's my second business venture.
Hello?
Sir?
What about the cheese?
This?
The cheese market is going up!
There is a cheese shortage right now in France!
They're going on their 500th strike!
It's their anniversary!
We're striking!
Okay.
Nice.
Powdered sugar.
Okay.
41.
50.
8.
2.
Area.
Wait.
Is it profit?
Guys!
Cheese!
Oh my god.
Why does no one want the cheese?
Is the music not...
It's the music.
The music is not inciting cheese purchases.
Guys, we need...
We need...
The music is not giving me cheese vibes!
We need better music!
We need more cheese music!
What do I do?
Cheese copyright free.
Right?
Free...
Music.
Okay.
Cheese copyright free music.
What do I get?
Does it sound like cheese?
I can't tell.
This is 2 minutes long so I don't know.
Supermarket.
Royalty free stock supermarket.
Why is it so...
Oh hey.
Supermarket stock videos.
Is there music on that?
There is!
There's supermarket stock videos!
More songs.
Okay.
It's not copyright free.
Reupload.
Sounds for the supermarket.
Oh my god!
Sounds for the supermarket!
Okay.
If you're looking for a classic then look no further.
This music contains inaudible subliminal recordings that were intended to increase buyer purchases!
Oh!
Oh my god!
The description is perfect!
Guys!
It says here that it...
This music contains inaudible subliminal recordings that were intended to increase buyer purchasing at grocery stores.
Customers were influenced to purchase more products as a result of the brain wave patterns hidden in the musical notes and the sound composition.
This is it.
This will get me all the cheese purchases.
I found it!
Here you go!
Will you buy my cheese now?
We're so imersive!
Guys!
Oh my god!
It makes you wanna buy the cheese!
Super chat!
Now!
Okay, 2851.
Alright,
36.98.
Oh my god, look at all these customers!
It's working!
It just works!
Why suddenly I feel the urge to buy cheese.
Mr. Toon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, it should work!
It should work!
There's two more hours!
The music, it's compelling me!
Thank you for the super chat, Ivan.
Thank you, thank you.
You can't resist.
You can't resist!
The music!
Come on, come on.
Sir, sir, you know you want.
Sir, sir, sir, the cheese is right there.
No, sir!
Sir, we have an hour left!
There's still hope!
Someone please!
For some reason I'm compelled to send this super chat.
It's just thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It just works!
It just works, guys!
Guys!
Cheese, please!
Please, we have five seconds.
Please, come in.
Come in for the cheese.
Come on, come on, come on, come on.
No, that's not the cheese!
Come on, head to the cheese.
Head to the cheese.
Yes!
Ba-da-dum!
Ba-ba-ba- No!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It works on everything but the cheese!
No!
But it says...
Ba-dum, ba-bum...
Ba-da-dum...
Okay, this is a good song.
They're not gonna lie.
Now I know why people buy more.
Ba-da-dum...
Wait, is that cheese?
Oh, it worked!
We did it!
It just works!
It just works, guys!
Oh my...
Here, take that one cent for free!
Oh my god!
You deserve it, sir!
That one cent!
Our first $1000!
Mika, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
I don't know what happened.
But it happened.
Ba-da-dum!
Weird.
How did I get here, MrFroken?
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
It just works.
And look at that!
My water!
It's gone!
Alright, and...
Wait, did all the cheese stuff fell down, too?
No, wait.
No, it's the same.
Ba-da-dum...
Suddenly I think I want to buy cereal.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
Jen, thank you for the super sticker!
Wait, what's over here?
Oh, my bread!
Okay, we need bread.
Guys, we did it!
We made our first thousand!
We made it!
We were here!
Oh my god, look at all these items were almost sold out.
Look at that!
It works, the subliminal messaging!
I knew...
I knew there was science to it!
I'm the best employee!
Burrito, thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you!
I thought Doki was a gamer, but she's all about the cheese.
I have always been all about the cheese!
I've been cheesing every video game I touch.
Look at that!
I think that subliminal music has worked better for the water than the cheese.
Not gonna lie.
Please, we're three levels away!
We're three levels away!
Please, buy my stuff!
Buy my merch!
Please!
Alright, we need...
We need to pay our bills though.
Bill...
Bill.
Alright.
I think I can afford...
You know what?
I think I can afford another fridge.
No!
I think I can afford...
I think I can afford another license.
What do I need?
Level 6.
Peanut butter, flour, olive oil, pasta, rice, and salt!
I have the money.
It's time.
Alright.
Ba dum ba da dum!
Guys!
One water?
Good choice, good choice.
$3 water with your card.
That's good, that's good, that's good.
Alright.
35...
1 cent.
Alright.
We gotta stock it up.
Please, we're so close to...
Peanut butter.
Okay, we put peanut butter here.
And then, we gotta make sure nobody buys peanut butter...
Now.
Okay, $7.
There you go.
Want milk?
No problem, sir.
Oh, thank you for the exact change!
Alright, salt.
Put the salt right here.
Oh my god, we're expanding so hard right now.
Look at that.
And also some rice!
Some rice with your spaghetti!
That's right!
So guys, give me a sec.
Please don't buy my stuff yet!
$4.
Uhhh...
$9.
There you go.
Guys, this is very expensive rice.
It's imported.
All my stuff here is imported.
Uhh...
From America.
I never said where it's imported!
Did I say Madagascar?
Peanut oil?
I meant Madagascar City.
I meant Madagascar City, guys.
And did I say like Little... Did I say Italy?
I meant Little Italy in New York City.
It is imported!
Just not where you think it's imported.
Guys!
You don't want to support the grandmas in Little Italy?
I agree.
Yeah, I meant the Madagascar.
Madagascar movie themed oil.
You know like how like...
Like companies like to sell vegetables to kids.
They just put like cartoon characters on there.
To like...
To like try to convince...
Like there's nothing different between the vegetables.
It's literally just like...
Like they just slap Shrek there to be...
Make you eat more veggies.
Because they're like, oh my god!
Look!
This carrot!
These carrots have Shrek's face on it!
Eat your veggie, kids!
So it's basically like that.
I slapped the Madagascar movie.
It's just marketing.
Nice.
There you go.
Okay.
I think it's time.
I think it's time to change...
Swap up the music.
Even I'm going crazy.
I think...
I'm lowkey going crazy with this song.
So I...
For the sake of everybody's sanity.
I'm going to swap.
The music.
Okay.
I was about to spend money too.
I was almost about to spend money.
The background music is melting my brain.
Do not worry.
Why...
I saved this all.
I was like...
Oh no.
I'm about to do retail therapy.
I had to stop myself as well for all of us.
For all of us, it was for the greater good.
Let me find better music real fast.
Honestly, I didn't really hear...
I genuinely work in a grocery store.
I feel... yeah, I think workers who had to work...
Like the supermarket workers that had to listen to the...
I'm pretty sure they don't change up the songs, right?
At the supermarket or at any targets or whatever.
They don't really change up the song.
So every day you're just listening to the same song over and over and over again.
Every single day.
I would fucking go crazy.
Oh my god.
I think I would go crazy too.
Okay.
I mean, not that they don't.
Yeah, they do not.
I'm here for an excuse.
Creepism not bringing you back to hell.
Yeah.
Don't worry.
I'm here to help you escape from the torture of Weiji Keiji.
Alright, let's see.
I need to find...
There was this channel that I really like for copyright-free music.
But I need to find it again.
I need to find it again, guys.
Just give me a sec.
God damn it.
Where is it?
It's one of my favorite... like...
background BGMs place because it was copyright-free and it was really nice.
It was like a Korean channel too.
I just need to find the channel again because it's been a while.
Where is it?
No!
We can't go crazy!
No, it's not Doba Syndrome.
It's like a Korean...
It's a Korean one and it's really nice.
Oh wait, did they change the...
Wait, is it this one?
Where is the free music?
No, it's not this one.
What was it?
I'm trying to remember the...
The...
Yeah, there was like this really good...
Really good Korean channel for copyright BGM music.
Uhhhh...
I'm trying to like remember...
What it was called.
Oh, is it this one?
I'm gonna try this one.
Uhhhh...
Is it this channel?
No, it wasn't this channel.
It was not this one.
It was like a blue...
It was a blue...
Icon.
It was a blue icon.
Not this one.
It was so cute too!
They had such cute music.
Oh, I found it!
I found it.
I found it, guys.
It's one of my favorite BGM...
It's called...
This is the one I use.
This is the BGM place I use usually.
Their stuff is like super cute.
And they have a lot.
I love using this.
There you go.
Now we can be less insane.
Alright, here you go.
Hahaha!
Ba dum.
Ba dum ba dum ba dum.
Now I can be stuck in a cage for a little bit longer.
Sanity restoring.
I can work in a cage a little longer.
Is that great?
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You still work in electronic style and the song playlist was bad.
But during Christmas, it was literally torture.
Oh yeah, all the Mariah Carey's.
The thing is, there's not a lot of Christmas music too.
Especially for one that you have to do it for hours and hours straight.
There's not enough music to keep up for Christmas season.
There's like what?
Two hours max of songs.
All I want for Christmas is you.
Hahaha!
Alright, let's see.
Uh, wait.
Oh, I'm giving.
Wait.
Whoops, sorry.
This is not that.
I don't know why I tried to give you like $16 there.
Give me a sec.
Please be patient.
I'm stupid.
Uh, there you go.
That was the longest 47 cents ever.
Coffee!
Extra coffee?
No, I have extra tea.
Alright.
At least I'm almost...
I'm almost done.
Level 8.
Please.
Please buy from my store.
I need more shoppers.
Sir, no!
Please!
I need to be level 10!
Hahaha!
Please!
Don't you want me to hire a teenager and pay the minimum wage, sir?
And give them real life working experience?
Sir!
Think of the minimum wage teenager!
Alright.
Cereal.
Nope.
Hahaha!
They need this job to buy their graphics card!
Alright.
Nice.
Let's see.
30 at 2.51.
Whoops.
Nice.
Cereal!
Hahaha!
Please let me employ this minimum wage teenager for their first work experience!
Think of the teenager!
Okay.
Two...
Forty...
One cents.
There you go.
Alright.
Where's your money?
Four dollars.
Bam.
Okay.
I'm gonna go buy some coffee.
Oh no.
No one wants to work here.
Where are the lights?
You don't need lights!
Use your eyes!
You have eyes!
We have built-in night vision!
Wait.
I've messed up my fucking playlist already.
Hahaha!
You don't need it!
We have built-in night vision!
Do it!
Yes!
We do!
The longer we work in the dark, the better evolved we are.
Alright.
Thank you, ma'am, for thinking about the teenagers and letting me hire one for minimum wage.
Hahaha!
Oh yeah!
It's better to hide prices in darkness too!
That's the best part!
If they can't see the price, they don't know it's overpriced.
Hahaha!
We are a store that cares about our customers' vision.
If you guys don't know, some people are living with sensitive eyes.
We are here for those people.
It's all about the au naturel.
Hahaha!
We are the au naturel store.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh no.
No!
The oil!
Not the oil cell!
Okay.
We will make it for the others' profit.
No!
Oh
wait!
That's not the oil.
That's not the oil I work with.
Oh no.
It is.
Hahaha!
Oh!
My brain working for minimum wage.
Hahahahaha!
I love it here.
Joki!
Please!
Please, thank you for the  .
Thank you.
It's my birthday day so I want to give you something back.
Thank you for making us smile, Joki.
Thank you.
I'm glad you have been enjoying your time.
Happy birthday to you.
It's hard to sing with this song in the background.
Happy birthday dear, Rodrigo.
Happy birthday to you.
Alright,
is there anything else we need?
I feel like we have... okay, rice.
Oh, olive oil.
Okay, we'll grab olive oil.
We'll grab another cup of flour.
And then, what else?
What else do we need?
Okay, do we have shells for it?
Okay, we have two, three.
We have two, three.
Okay.
And then pasta, spaghetti.
We're so close to level A.
Okay, spaghetti.
Spaghetti.
Somebody would need the spaghetti!
Give me a sec.
I need to put down supreme flour.
Uhh, spaghetti.
Okay, market price.
Okay.
I'm gonna do 7.50.
And then...
No, no, do not buy the average cost!
I need profit!
7.7.
There we go.
Butter, butter.
Nice, thank you for... We have new flour!
Would you like new flour?
Alright.
37.05.
Do you really care about that five cents, sir?
God damn it.
You and your fucking...
$100 bill for one fucking flour.
Milk!
We need milk!
Milk.
Nice.
Okay.
Milk.
Oh shit!
Wait, I bought...
Oh, I forgot about the oil!
I forgot about the oil!
Please!
No, my milk!
Can my milk get run over by a car?
I'm asking for scientific purposes.
Alright.
Nice.
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
Okay.
90 cents.
Guys, we're almost there.
We're almost at level eight.
Plus five.
Guys, we're gonna hit the big eight!
The big eight!
Two dollars.
Oh my god, I'm so fast at this now.
Can I upgrade my store now?
Management Grove.
Oh my god, section two!
We don't need to expand though, I feel like.
I think like we're cozy.
Honestly.
Like, we're cozy.
We're cozy here.
What does expanding do for us anyway?
Like, it's not like more people are gonna show up.
Like...
If you think about it.
Like, I don't think more people are...
is just gonna show up to my store.
Oh shit, I'm running out of coffee now.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I need to buy coffee.
Where's coffee?
Uhhh...
Dark roast.
Okay.
There we go.
Stop, stop sir!
Stop!
Coffee's coming!
Ahhh!
There's too many boxes!
Alright, let's see.
Thirty one point fifty three.
Guys, don't worry.
When the teenager is here, I'll start throwing the boxes away.
I just don't have time right now.
We're just gonna stockpile some...
It's called the environment.
We're gonna reuse, resell.
We're gonna sell the boxes.
People will wanna use the boxes to carry their stuff home, you know?
Don't you know, like at Costco, there's like a ton of boxes that you can just like pick up?
That's what it is!
You know what I'm talking about?
It's called saving the environment.
You guys wouldn't understand.
You guys don't love the environment as much as me.
Oh my god.
Look at that.
We're almost level nine.
Wait, do you want a card?
Okay, card.
Please.
All I wanna do is just hire...
Why is...
Why do you have to be level ten to hire the minimum wage worker?
I don't understand.
Like, I'm literally giving him free money.
I'm a good boss too.
I'm a good boss.
Let me hire him.
Oh, the olive oil!
Oh no!
Stop buying the olive oil!
I'm not making profit!
Stop!
I forgot the olive oil!
Okay.
Alright, the last level.
For the last level, we're gonna have a big sale.
But for now, we need to make money.
Stop buying yellow.
No!
I lost all the oil!
Too many people took advantage of the poor businesswoman!
Okay, oil.
I need to restock it apparently.
I lost weed.
Just go out of business.
Don't anybody think of the fucking poor businesswoman.
Oh my god, my water!
I need water too!
Okay.
Please just wait at the cashier.
I'm getting water.
It's called tax loss arms.
Give me a sec!
There's so many boxes!
Okay, 14.
Alright.
Cash.
One dollar.
Nice.
Okay.
There we go.
We're just gonna keep stocking boxes here.
No, nobody's buying my cheese anymore.
The cheese market crashed.
Oh, I can't believe we lived long enough to see the cheese market crashing.
Oh wait, I didn't see you there.
Guys, it's not too dark here, okay?
I just had my eyes closed.
It's so cold.
It's okay.
No, I can totally see!
My eyes were just closed.
Lord, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Gotta manifest your destiny and get more oil.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
I can't believe it.
The cheese bubble burst.
How will France sustain themselves now?
What else are they gonna export?
France, the city in America, of course.
I'm talking about the city of France in America.
Where's your hand?
There it is.
Oh, it's not.
Do you have anything you want to sell?
Okay.
Card, okay.
Nice, we're almost halfway there.
Little France.
Paris, Texas.
Exactly!
Somebody understands!
How much?
$372 profit!
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Even with the oil situation, we did it.
Ah, shit.
Okay.
Um...
I...
What were the...
Okay, um...
Okay, guys.
What do I need to restock?
Okay, peanut butter.
Peanut butter.
Coffee.
Um...
Rice!
Rice went up!
Oh my God!
Who cares about fucking...
Oh, pasta.
I need pasta.
Pasta.
What else?
No, not the salt market!
No!
But how much?
Not the salt market!
It's fine, we'll keep it there.
I don't remember what I said.
What else do I have to stock up?
Okay.
Spaghetti.
Oh, the oil.
I need to remember the oil.
It's fine.
And then...
Rice.
Okay, rice is up now.
We don't... It's okay.
Uh...
This is stuff I still have.
You know what?
We'll keep this.
And then... coffee.
Okay.
Restock.
Restock spot and the non-restock.
Uh... peanut butter.
And then we need...
We need pasta.
We need pasta!
Oil.
Okay, uh...
Pasta.
Where's pasta?
Where's my fucking pasta?
Alright, pasta.
And normal oil.
Alright.
I'm gonna go like this?
I don't have my minimum wage worker!
What am I supposed to do?
You think I'm throwing this at myself?
That's what the teenagers are for.
Oh, I already have...
Fuck you, you're in pot pasta!
Okay.
Alright, we're fine.
It's okay, here you go.
It's okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Is there anything else we're missing?
What else are we missing?
My back stock is insane.
Flour!
Okay.
Flour.
Alright.
Bam.
Is there anything else?
Please.
It can go higher.
Sugar?
Where's the sugar?
Oh yeah, sugar.
Okay, we have sugar.
Where's sugar?
Okay, here.
Anything else?
We don't have enough...
Okay, we can...
We'll put room temperature sugar until...
Oh, I have an idea!
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, I have an idea.
Do I have a milk box?
Do I have a milk box anywhere?
We'll put the eggs in there when we have enough room.
I'm not buying another fridge!
That's too much money!
Oh wait, that's used.
Okay, this can go higher.
There we go.
We're ready.
We're ready for business.
We've restocked, I think.
Okay, I'm gonna double check.
Oil, water, peanut butter, flour...
Yeah, we stocked everything.
There you go.
Guys!
Stop judging me!
I'm just...
I'm just a single parent.
The doki amber does!
She try to make things work and have foods!
Like...
People don't care about what it looks like on the inside!
It's all about the...
...the food!
It's all about the food!
I have quality food!
Flower.
Boop boop boop boop boop boop boop.
Okay.
I almost...
Oh god.
I can't... this can be higher.
No!
This can be higher.
There you go.
Guys.
Go to you guys.
Nice.
Okay.
Boop boop boop boop boop boop.
43.
We're almost...
The moment we hit level 9.
We're gonna go on a big sale guys.
We're gonna go on a big sale.
Speed run to level 10.
25.50 Alright.
Here we go.
This is good.
We need someone to buy more.
On this episode on hoarders.
We are toking with boxes.
This is not a choice.
Cruising.
Thank you for the support.
Super chat.
Thank you.
It's not a choice.
It's a problem.
And I'm willing to admit it.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
19.
Nice.
Plus 5.
Please.
We need you to get rid of the cheese and the milk.
So I can...
put the eggs.
The eggs are at room temperature lady.
Please.
My eggs are at room temperature.
Someone please.
Take the... think of the eggs.
You never know.
Exactly.
You never know when you need a box.
Now we're thinking.
This is what happens when your streamer isn't forklift certified.
Look.
I'm almost close to 1000.
OMG.
Look at all the stuff she's buying.
And she paid an exact...
That's the customer I like.
Oh my god!
It's happening!
Guys!
We have eggs!
Finally!
There we go.
Oh my god, we finally have eggs.
It's happening.
It's fucking happening!
Oh my god, imagine a charger like $150.
Okay, we need water.
Oh my god, did you guys see that tweet of this manager in Japan that accidentally ordered 999 onigiris?
And he's like, please, it expires in one day.
We need people to buy onigiris.
That's gonna be me.
I'm gonna accidentally use my...
entire savings and order like 999 eggs.
Oh shit.
Give me a sec, lady.
I'm trying to calculate.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you for buying...
buying our stuff.
Yeah, they actually did!
Because it went viral!
Because people were like, why the fuck do you have so much eggs?
Not eggs, only giri!
Like, people around...
Like, people in the area just went and helped this poor...
poor man who accidentally ordered 999 onigiris.
Alright, I'm gonna accidentally like...
buy more stock of things I never needed.
Oh wait, 7.
I see 7.
Okay, do I have bread?
There must... do I have...
I have cheese.
Wait, I have cheese.
I know I have cheese.
There we go.
And then flour.
Okay, now I already have flour.
Okay.
Oil!
Nice.
Um...
Oh, I can rotate it!
Oh my god!
Oh, it changes everything.
This changes everything.
I can rotate...
No!
Wait, there's stuff in this box.
Wait, there was stuff in this box.
There we go.
Okay, nice.
I had enough time.
19.5.
Okay.
Water.
Spaghet.
Do I have... do I need to put more flour?
No.
Flour is good.
What about salt?
Why does no one want the salt?
You need to season your food!
Please think about your seasoning!
30.
What in the...
Oh, nice.
Exact change.
Okay.
Peanut butter and bread.
Do I have peanut butter?
Do I... do you need coffee?
Okay.
Coffee.
Nice.
Oh.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, sir.
37.4.
Nice.
All right.
We need...
We need peanut butter and bread.
I'm a little concerned that my bread has been on that shelf for like four days now.
But it's okay.
It's okay.
People love it when it's a little stale.
If it's too soft, then it's for pussies.
Where's the door?
Everybody likes it when the bread is a little hard.
Guys.
Okay.
I think...
Where's the cashier entrance area?
There.
All right.
23.
Nice.
Okay.
Here we go.
1, 2, 3.
50.
60.
70.
80.
There you go.
What did you buy?
I can't tell.
What was that?
I see your items.
7.
25.
40.
45.
There you go.
Where's your card?
Okay.
There you go.
92.
Holy shit.
2.
There.
Nice.
Oh.
We got a big spender here.
He's a personroiftingsperson.
Providing for his family.
30.65.
Oh.
My god.
We're almost at level 9!
This is it.
Wait.
Lady.
Shop is done.
Oh.
You're just gonna come here.
The store is closed.
You're just gonna come here and fucking...
Fucking...
Talk about how fucking expensive my store is.
It's fucked up, man.
Wait.
I can keep making sales.
There's more people coming in.
I don't have enough money.
Why are people coming in?
Don't tell me.
Oh my god, he bought all the oil!
The oil is still ready.
Alright, now we can end the day.
How much money?
Products found expensive, $31.
Well, we don't care about you.
No, my cheese!
Cheese!
Okay, my spaghetti is okay.
What is this?
Is this bread?
Okay.
Oh!
It's okay.
It's okay, we're gonna stack this nice and tall.
There we go.
We're gonna make sure...
No!
What is the physics?
Okay.
You know what?
That's fine.
Okay.
It's fine!
People can still walk around it!
Uh... Do I need flour?
I do.
There we go.
It's okay!
As long as people can walk around it, it's fine.
Uh... Do I need pasta?
No... Wait, is this not pasta?
What is this?
What am I carrying?
Is this flour?
Did I run out of flour?
Oh, I did.
Oh my god, people love flour.
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna have our biggest sale.
The moment I can put this away.
Okay, we need to have a... People still need to be able to access the oil.
This is the second part of the gameplay.
I'm really paying you to do... Fine!
Fine!
There you go.
That's how much that's worth.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's the market value for me to throw away my box.
It's like the recycling fee, you know?
Like when you recycle a box, you get paid like...
Um... An amount for recycling... For bringing your recyclables over.
Yeah, like when you recycle bottles and fucking cardboard boxes.
Oh yeah, like in Germany, there's like these like machines.
I was like watching YouTube short and there's like this machine that like lets you...
That like basically you have to put... If you don't recycle it, you have to give the money.
You have to like... There's like a fee to pay if you don't recycle.
But then if you recycle, they give you money.
Please, the box...
It looks like my living room.
Oh yeah, another fee!
There you go.
Here's one box.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
That is...
What was that?
Wait, what is this?
I don't... I don't remember what I have in my shop.
It's so long.
Oh, cereal!
It was the cereal!
Cereal...
We need more oil.
What do I need?
I don't remember.
There's too many items.
I'm getting confused.
Cereal...
Okay, we got cereal.
Do we have sugar?
We have sugar.
I'm getting too confused.
There's too many items in my fucking...
Okay.
I feel like there was something at the bottom there.
What the fuck was there?
I have boxes.
Okay.
There you go.
Please throw another one out.
Here for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Alright.
Box disposal fee!
Thank you.
Okay.
Fine!
You get two boxes!
You get two boxes.
Alright.
What else in my...
Flower was at the...
But I already have a flower.
Do I have two flowers?
I have two flowers.
I think that was it, right?
I think that's everything.
That should be everything.
I'm pretty sure.
Wait.
I need to put more cheese.
I'm running out of cheese.
Wait.
Is it cheese?
Is that cheese?
Oh!
My eggs!
I forgot... Oh, wait.
No.
I already have eggs.
Okay.
Cheese.
I need cheese.
Alright.
Cheese.
There you go.
Okay.
We're gonna...
We're gonna do something wild here.
Alright, guys.
We're gonna go to our biggest cell yet.
Okay.
295.
3.
Alright.
We're gonna make it so that we only make one dollar profit.
So we can speedrun to level 10.
I'm...
We're gonna...
We're gonna speedrun.
We're gonna speedrun this shit now.
Okay.
Let's see.
5.
There we go.
Please.
Buy my stuff!
It's so cheap now!
It's such a steal!
Buy my... Oh my god!
I was $10!
Oh my god.
My shit was so expensive.
Holy fuck.
No wonder people didn't wanna fucking shop here.
Biggest cell yet!
Buy!
4.
Okay.
6.
Please!
I'm begging you to rob me at this point!
This is highway robbery!
Oh, I need more flour.
Wait, do I have flour in here?
There's so many things.
I'm literally paying you guys to fucking rob me!
I bought the wrong flour.
Sorry, the flour was red.
There's too many flours!
Okay.
Here we go.
We're gonna put this here.
Okay.
We have our own stock now.
I'm gonna forget what I do have.
I'm pretty sure.
Come!
Carl, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm robbing your store.
Please!
Put me out of business!
I'm letting you put me out of business!
Just get me out of here!
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm not making you put me out of business that easily.
Seven dollars.
Alright.
I need to get that sugar in here.
Nice.
Okay.
Honestly, I don't know.
There's too many items here.
Why did I order so much peanut butter?
Why do I have so much peanut butter?
Alright.
Eighteen.
Nice.
Wait, did I exit paying or less?
No!
Guys, please!
I didn't mean to actually steal from me!
Please come back and give me back the money!
Please!
I'm just a local business person.
Umm...
Okay.
I'm just gonna go ahead and go.
Flour.
I think it's this.
Okay, and then oil.
Oh no.
Water.
Okay.
Spaghet.
Please, I'm getting overwhelmed right now.
Thank you for the acasupa!
Thank you!
Acasupa for your taste in dog breeds.
Please give them to Pep for the random interest.
Thank you!
Thank you for the acasupa!
How do you say it's too expensive?
You're literally...
There's prop...
I'm literally asking you to steal from me.
This is almost the same price as Whole Foods!
Oh my god.
What do I need to restock?
350.
Okay.
$20.
Oh, that is a lot of stuff you're buying.
Water.
Okay.
Water is done.
Cheese.
Cheese is done.
This flower.
Oh, no one wants this flower.
No one likes that flower.
Okay.
Coffee!
Okay, we need coffee.
What do we need?
Coffee!
Tea!
Tea.
Please sir, wait a minute!
I'm getting...
Overwhelmed!
Tea!
Sugar!
Ah!
Yeah, that's it!
Oh my god, that's...
Okay.
Checkout.
Oh my god.
Please.
Okay, I need...
I need to stock up.
Where's the sugar?
Okay, get in here.
Fox, get in here!
Pasta!
Sir, please!
I'm sorry!
13.6.
Alright, one customer.
One restock.
Tea.
Nice, we're restocking everything.
And then...
Coffee!
Guys, do you guys want to look more?
Look at the beautiful things we have!
Do you want...
Do I look more to a shop more?
We got a recent restock!
Oh no, this is too big of a sale.
I was not...
I was not made for all this sale.
Okay.
Eggs.
Oh!
What am I missing?
Um... Where's my eggs?
We had sugar all this long?
Okay.
All this long I already had sugar.
Flour!
We need the other flour!
We need the rich man flour!
Wait no, that's pasta.
There you go.
Okay.
Where's the rich man flour?
Water.
Oh, there's too much of a line!
Oh my god.
This is not going so well, guys.
Okay, one dollar.
Nice.
Uh...
Card.
19.
I liked it better when my store wasn't accessible.
When my store was harder to afford.
Okay.
Let's see.
48.
Uh...
I can't stop buying everything.
Please!
I don't have enough free stock!
Ah!
What's this?
Flour!
Oh, let's just put in two flours.
I don't need all that flour.
Yeah, more sugar!
More sugar!
We don't need all that.
Ah!
What's this?
Is this salt?
What is this?
What am I holding?
Is this peanut butter?
Okay, peanut butter is here now.
Hahaha!
Okay.
Uh... 25.3 Please, we're so close.
We're halfway to level 10!
We're so close to level 10!
18.05 Is that cash?
Okay, 73.
Oh, that's not... No, that's not right.
Okay.
Uh... $2.
Anyone want more stuff?
Where's the restock?
I don't know.
You go here.
Do I have more items?
What is this?
Peanut butter.
One peanut butter!
Do I have anything else in the corner?
I don't think so.
We're good.
16.
It's fine.
Yay!
Uh... 45.
Here you go.
There's so many people that wanna shop!
$1.
Nice.
Is that it?
Is that everybody?
Oh my god, is that it?
Am I free?
No, I put so many boxes.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Holy fuck.
Okay.
Alright.
This is fine.
This is...
This is absolutely fine.
Okay.
Cereal.
Um...
What do we need?
Oil.
Um...
Do we have the red pasta?
Red pasta.
Sugar.
Wait, we have too much sugar now.
Bottled water.
Oh my god!
There's nothing left in my fridge!
Bottled water.
Cheese.
You know what?
I'm adding two of each.
I maxed it out?
Okay.
Uh...
Okay, we're gonna get rid of...
Okay, we're gonna restart from one.
Okay.
Two.
Alright, first two rows.
We've done the first two rows.
Okay.
Okay, and then...
Two.
Alright.
Okay.
We're good.
Alright.
And then the last two.
Two.
There we go.
Okay, we're fine.
This is good.
This is so helpful now.
We're okay.
We're almost at level ten, guys!
Flour.
Okay, that is going here.
And then... milk.
Alright.
Milk at the bottom.
Alright, and then...
And then...
Here's our oil.
Our oil!
Yay!
That is how it feels to work at Dollar Tree.
Thank you for the super chat.
Okay, we're gonna put like unopened ones here.
Okay, flour.
Alright, flour goes here.
That's an empty box, right?
Yeah, it is.
It's empty.
Okay, milk.
Okay, we're gonna put like the unopened ones here.
So I know it's unopened.
We have a system.
Guys, we have a system now.
Guys...
This is our system.
It's gonna work.
Okay, cereal.
Like, customers don't care about what it looks like.
Okay?
Customers do not care.
As long as they can get their daily necessities.
That's all that matters.
Okay, flour.
Okay, we have unopened flour.
Okay, salt.
Cereal.
Alright.
It's fine.
Where am I?
Oh my god, I teleported right in there.
Alright.
Rice.
Restock central.
Uh, oil.
Oh wait.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, this had to be unopened.
Um...
This other oil.
Okay, the other oil we don't need yet.
Coffee.
Okay.
We don't need a storage room!
We do not need the extra space!
We have all the necessary space we need!
It's fine!
Okay, peanut butter.
Peanut butter goes here.
Hahahaha!
This is all the space we need!
It works!
It just works!
Okay, and then we'll put the cereal here.
And then the cheese goes here.
Thank you for the cereal, chat.
Thank you.
Everything just works!
Who the fuck?
Okay, here we go.
Alright.
And then... You know what?
Big customers can come in right now.
Okay?
Okay.
Eggs.
Alright.
Eggs time.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh, Doki, please!
We need money!
We need to make money!
I can't spend all my time restocking shelves!
Guys!
I can't waste my time restocking shelves, guys!
We need to make money!
Look, he's happy with his one box of sugar!
Tsk!
Hahahaha!
Alright.
I love my having my eggs in the sun for like five minutes.
That sounds ideal.
Please release me from the dirtiest boxes!
Hahahaha!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
And that's bread.
Alright, here we go!
We have... It's like Costco!
You guys always wanted a Costco!
It's... It's like Costco, guys!
It almost feels just like Costco.
Okay.
All these boxes were like Costco.
Okay, $30.
Uh... $20.
Okay, we can restock.
Where are my...
Okay, we need...
Wait, what was over there?
Coffee.
Where's my coffee?
Guys, give me a sec!
I know I have another box of coffee somewhere!
Guys!
Give me a sec!
I'm trying to find my box of coffee!
It's in this pile!
I know I bought extra!
There we go!
There's my extra coffee.
There we go.
Don't worry, guys.
I'm restocking!
It's not falling apart!
It's a system!
It's a fucking system!
One box, please.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, $80.
Uh...
$4.
Even...
Okay...
Divertoge is like, we have a problem.
Even he's acknowledging that there's something wrong.
Okay, don't worry.
$6.6.
Alright, we're good, we're good.
One, two...
Uh...
$95.
Milk.
Okay, $3.5.
System!
Working well, I see.
It is!
Where's my peanut butter?
I know I had a lot of peanut butter!
Okay...
That's flour.
Where did all my peanut butter go?
Okay...
Where did it all go?
I'm gonna put this away, though.
Ugh...
Okay...
I can restock the water.
Ugh...
And the milk.
Y'all can put all that milk away.
It's okay.
It's okay, everything is fine.
Everything is fine.
I know I bought more!
It's okay, we're almost at level 10!
We're almost at level 10, guys!
Cereal.
Someone just bought one cereal, that's okay.
You do you.
Rice.
Oh my God.
My foxes!
Please!
Please go down!
It's okay.
That's okay, we're almost at level 10!
We're almost there!
Okay, 6.
We did it!
We can hire our middle-waged teenager!
Oh my god, I need to pay my bills too.
Okay, where are you?
Hiring.
We did it!
Do your job!
I just need a stock!
Stock, stock, stock!
Oh my god, it's finally here!
It's finally here!
Everything we worked for... is here!
Oh my god!
We did it!
This worked for me.
Yes.
Keep working.
I... what do I need a stock for?
Just put more bread, I don't care at this point.
Do I need eggs?
Eggs?
I think I need eggs.
Don't worry.
Everything's fine.
Milk.
I think we need more milk, right?
Yeah, we need more milk.
Now I can do what I've always wanted to do.
Start stacking this better.
Now I have more time for what I'm actually passionate about.
Okay, okay.
Okay, TM, because I don't want to get sued after 081 box.
You know what?
In celebration, we can turn on the lights now.
Rejoice, everybody!
Today is a celebration!
In celebration, we can turn on the lights!
Go, Jerry!
Go!
Wait, is that Elon Musk?
Before he invented... before he was a rich kid, Pia King was my cashier.
This is it!
Announcement!
Announcement.
We have decided... the company has decided to get rid of all natural light.
And decided to cater to the... to the light people.
We have decided to cater to the people that have been demanding for lights.
So I apologize to all the light sensitive folks out there.
It was just more money.
Like we just... there was just more people that are not light sensitive.
So we just cater for more money.
We sold out.
All in all...
Ever since I got my minimum wage teenager...
We sold out.
Mr. Broken Bond, thank you, thank you for the super chat.
I need to make some artwork of Doki trying to juggle the box with that check.
It's fine!
I did it!
We did it, guys!
I ran out of turnip oil.
Oh no.
Now I can put more boxes away.
We did it, everybody!
Oh my god, we finally did it!
I had a dream...
To open the best Whole Foods out there.
And I think I did it.
I think I made it.
Good job, I think it was the super chat thing.
Thank you!
You know I think that is a good time.
I think this is a good way to call it for this game.
I think we made a lot of progress, you know?
In general.
I honestly think we did really good today.
Okay.
GG's everybody!
GG's!
Not gonna lie!
Honestly, I think my best...
The best store I've ever opened.
Oh my god.
Oh!
I had to leave like three times in anxiety!
What do you mean?
It was perfect!
I think I knew how to run a store.
I think I knew how to run a perfect grocery market.
Devlin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I just posted.
Your box situation is still not as bad as mine.
Devlin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What do you mean?
What do you mean by that?
What the fuck did you do to your store?
Holy fuck!
I thought you meant in-game!
Bro!
Look, I have in-game problems.
This is IRL problems.
Oh my god!
Bro!
Are you okay?
Are you okay, man?
For those who know what the fuck he sent, this is...
Oh shit, wait.
This is what he sent me.
Like...
I thought you meant in-game!
I thought you meant in-game.
Oh my god, this is too real!
Too real!
Oh my god!
DM, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You made a hill of boxes.
This is what you made.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh, man!
Corporate corruption has fines for real though.
Nice work, boss.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
But yeah, that was fun!
That was really fun.
Not gonna lie, I feel like this is a game you can easily just autopilot to and just like...
Like, and just like...
Uh, like...
Seven hours can easily pass through just playing this game.
Cause it...
It's such an autopilot game that I feel like you can easily just have seven hours disappear so fast if you just play it non-stop.
Yeah, it's just fun!
I had a lot of fun ta- yeah, I had...
Um, I had a lot of fun playing it.
Uh, GoldenDragon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
At least you're not like Asmongold trash everywhere.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I've not seen xQc's room.
That man had like... put like carpet next to his like exposed GPU.
Like...
I mean like...
You know what I mean?
He had like months old chicken um, like underneath his desk.
I was there when I watched his livestream of him trying to build his PC.
That shit was scary.
Like, he like... he like sat on a chair made of Pepsi boxes.
Or was it Coke boxes?
One or the other.
This man is a millionaire.
And he fucking sat on a chair made of Coke boxes.
Like...
What?
Like Coca Cola boxes?
Oh my god.
Bro.
That shit is insane.
Oh my god.
Oh yeah.
I take out my trash?
What do you mean?
I actually... I actually go outside my room.
And that's the extent for what... for a bit.
And that's the extent for what...
for a bit.
Alright guys.
I'm gonna call it here everybody.
I hope you guys had a fun time hanging out with me.
Tomorrow is another rest day.
And um, I'm gonna be doing... getting a lot of work done today and tomorrow.
Cause I need to figure out who's gonna be joining Amelie and I for the...
for our collab game.
But yeah, thank you guys!
I had a great time.
Um...
Asasi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
As a person who was PC Tech, remind me to never watch XQC.
The stories are nearing man.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Alright guys.
I'm gonna call it here everybody.
As always everyone, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!